on passe maintenant notre chronique
junior notre journaliste
mais les poké nous a rejoints sur ce
plateau alors souvent pour beaucoup
rentrée des classes rime avec reprise
des activités sportives pour les enfants
et les adultes
les tout petits peuvent ainsi dépenser
mais la lie sur saint quentin les vignes
de nombreuses associations proposent des
activités et parce qu'en fait une
qu'elle les petits peuvent commencer le
sport des quatre ans des quatre mois au
pardon alors si vos enfants la bougeotte
pourquoi ne pas les inscrire à la baby
gym
bien sûr on est loin du sport de haut
niveau mais vos enfants vous quand même
se dépenser c'est surtout un temps de
partage entre les parents et les enfants
élisabeth meilhac a lancé cette activité
à l'association vivre à manille à magny
les hameaux et c'était il ya quarante
ans une activité corporelle mais une
activité aussi sensorielle puisque
l'enfant quand ils arrivent le bébé
puisque on prend les petits à partir de
6 mois une activité qui permet à
l'enfant de pratiquer
des jeux des exercices de motricité qui
vont lui permettre d'évoluer et de
s'éveiller à l'aide de ses parents alors
ça se passe bien su avec les parents
venaient d'entendre mais il ya aussi les
nounous les assistantes maternelles
deux créneaux ont lieu le mardi matin au
gymnase auguste delaune
il faut compter une heure d'activité et
il reste encore de la place mais ce
n'est pas la seule association à
proposer cette activité mélanie oui
alors c'est surtout l'activité la plus
présente pour les tout-petits parce que
la gym on peut la pratiquer avec la smb
baby gym de montigny-le-bretonneux il ya
les bout'choux qui sont accueillis dès
12 mois
la jem a est encore mort passage ans a
lancé sa section baby gym dès l'âge de
15 mois et l'association gymnastique
volontaire de plaisir accueillait les
potiers partir de 25 mois à ville preuve
on débute à deux ans donc à 24 mois avec
l'olympique gymnaste et pour les bébés
nageurs mais le large il y en a qui
aiment beaucoup barboter apparemment ça
rappellerait quand il était dans le
ventre de leur maman on part à montigny
le bretonneux et à guyancourt alors la
première commune propose cette activité
au centre aquatique du lac pour les
petits nez dès cette année les chronos
sont le samedi matin et à guyancourt et
les bébés vous dans l'eau dès l'âge de 6
mois
c'est surprenant mélanie merci beaucoup
en tout cas on se retrouve le mois
prochain